every restaurant in a franchise chain
has to reflect the culture and the
professionalism and the efficiency that
made it successful in the Freddy's
frozen custard and steak burgers well
first of all it's kind of a passion
project or at least it started that way
by the founders they kind of got
together and said what do we want to eat
and they made their menu specifically
about that they they wanted to have
burgers made to order they wanted them
smash Gaudin for the griddle so they get
crispy they liked frozen custard they
thought it was a more fun eating
experience than just ice cream one of
the founders had spent some time in
Chicago and wanted Chicago hot dogs so
they sat down on the road this this menu
and the whole project turned into a
passion project so it really came from
what it wasn't that they wanted and it
turns out a lot of other people did too
I'm Randy Simon
and I'm Scott Riddler my brother bill
and I and Scott were all in the
restaurant business for several years
Scott all of his life and Bill and I
were CPAs before we started in the
restaurant business and we both got into
franchising I was in a Bennett for 44
years and food gets in your blood it
really does years ago opened up a steak
I opened up a steakhouse and I needed a
partner and a great friend of ours
introduced bill and I and we ended up
becoming partners and really lifelong
friends it's an incredible relationship
that we had we miss him a lot
but we ended up opening at one time we
had six Timberline Steakhouse and girls
according to franchise Intel firm Fran
data it costs less to start a Freddy's
restaurant than it does a standalone
Burger King if the annual sales are
slightly higher that means that the
sales to investment ratio is better for
Freddy's franchisees they have a total
of 342 locations as of today and 27 of
those our company stores the balance of
them are all franchise stores so the
system has grown primarily through the
franchise mode but we did open six
company stores during nineteen eight art
during 2018 you know that's one of the
points of difference most or a lot of
franchise doors are so focused on
different things we're focused on our
company stores we're focused on the
success of our franchisees it's unusual
for a franchisor not to make back-end
dollars on any purchasing of equipment
food or any supplies and we don't our
goal is for our franchisees to be
successful and when they're successful
oh what happens oh wait they open more
restaurants more Freddy's and we all win
in that situation it's a lot more fun
being transparent and doing things the
Freddy's way the right way and it leads
to success for all that's part of the
reason that they have such a small
failure rate everybody knows how to run
this operation everybody knows how to
this game the way that the Freddie's
leadership wants it to be played a lot
of these really large chains that you've
heard about that everybody knows have
grown so much that there's not a lot of
territory to open up a company like
Freddie's can grow so fast and drill
into new territory specifically because
it's not massive we went over Freddie's
numbers with franchise expert Jeff
Leffler CEO of franchise great they've
consistently opened between 40 and 50
locations a year for the last five years
the majority of Freddie's franchisees
are multi-unit owners and that's one of
the reasons why they've been able to
scale at the continued pace that they
have since 2010 one of the interesting
things for me is is most franchise
systems have what we call franchisee
Tony
so this turnover happens if a franchise
location closes or kind of shuts down or
a contract with a franchisee is not
renewed so for context the average
franchisee travel rate franchise eternal
rate is nine point nine percent and
Freddie's is only two point eight but
that to me is a standout statistic in in
my mind as to why it's it's a noteworthy
opportunity these businesses just stay
running
they just don't close like you would see
in an average franchisee they just keep
going